los niños son ahora el foco de
preocupación en eeuu el país registra
sus peores niveles de contagio en 6
meses impulsados por la presencia de la
variante delta que es altamente
contagiosa además tiene el mayor número
de niños hospitalizados por el virus
desde que comenzó la pandemia lo que ha
provocado que los sindicatos de maestros
cambió su postura y ahora se muestren a
favor de la vacunación obligatoria para
los docentes
ahora bien permíteme decir que mis
miembros han dado un paso adelante el
90% de los profesores se han vacunado
creo que las circunstancias han cambiado
y que la vacunación es una
responsabilidad de la comunidad y me
pesan mucho que los niños menores de 12
años no puedan vacunarse una medida que
genera polémica a medida que cada vez
más empresas y negocios optan por qué
querer vacunas a sus empleados o
clientes y que podría generar tensiones
en los lugares de trabajo sindicalizados
con el regreso a clases también ha
vuelto la recomendación de uso de
mascarillas en las aulas con miras a
proteger a los niños expuestos al cob y
y rodearlos de los que se puedan vacunar
sean quienes sean profesores personal de
la escuela cualquiera que se vacune así
que protejamos a los niños con un
estudio de personas vacunadas sin
embargo en estados como florida actual
epicentro de contagios el gobernador
republicano ron de santis ha prohibido
los mandatos de tapabocas en los
colegios mientras tanto el reuso de la
población a vacunarse según los expertos
podría conducir al surgimiento de
posibles variantes todavía más fuertes
que la del táctica